hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
we've done a lot of sort of science on
the podcast over the years as it were
the podcast is old enough i can now say
over the years wow that's pretty
impressive
and doing science when you try to talk
about science to a
an audience which is not necessarily
full of specialists in that particular
kind of science
what do you do how do you talk about
science to non-scientists well the very
first thing you do
is you strip out all the math right you
assume that the people listening are not
necessarily familiar with the equations
the symbols
the manipulations that the professional
scientists have to go through
to understand their field but you can
nevertheless even without the math
you can talk about the concepts that the
scientists are dealing with
this raises a puzzle when the thing you
want to talk about
is math we haven't talked about math
as a pure subject that much here on
mindscape we did talk to
steven strogatz who's a professional
mathematician but he's very close to
being a physicist in many ways
we haven't quite ascended to the truly
abstract realms of very pure mathematics
so that's what we're doing here today
pure mathematics
no equations but we're going to try to
talk about the concepts that you come
across
at the most elevated realms of
mathematical thought
our guest today is emily real who is a
topologist at johns hopkins
and she's a very big believer in being
able to conceptualize these deep
mathematical ideas
in the simplest and best way possible so
she's a great person to guide us
on this tour and the foundational idea
we're going to be talking about is
topology
topology is the study of the properties
of mathematical spaces
that are invariant when you smush them
when you
smoothly deform them a little bit right
like if you have some
clay that is molded into a shape you can
talk about the number of holes in the
shape of clay that you have and then if
you move around the clay a little bit if
you don't rip it
the number of holes will remain constant
so that's a topological invariant
it turns out and this is where the fun
part comes that as a mathematician you
want to say okay
what do we mean by characterizing the
qualities of a mathematical space
that are invariant under smooth
deformations
well you can count the holes you can
also say well how many times can i make
a path that wraps around
the holes in this particular system
those kinds of structures
turn out to be numbers or
transformations or other things that we
can add together and multiply together
and we build these mathematical
algebraic structures
by asking the question how do we
topologically characterize
these kinds of spaces so we're led from
topology
into algebra and emily's going to take
us there we're going to discuss
things like homotopic groups rings
groupoids all these words that you're
not supposed to have necessarily
been familiar with already we're going
to discuss them and by the end
we're getting into what is called
category theory category theory is
something where
even the other mathematicians go oh no
that's too abstract for me
category theory is sort of a general
theory of spaces and structures and maps
between them
it provides a different way of thinking
about mathematics as a whole so i'm a
big believer that you know
math just like physics is part of the
general intellectual
conversation we should be having there
should be history and economics and math
and physics and
it would be a mistake to exclude math
from this overall intellectual discourse
and i think this conversation is a good
example of how we can do it
you know thinking like a mathematician
gives you new handles on the world just
like thinking like a physicist does
and so i think it's going to be fun
let's go
emily real welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you
you know i know that as a physicist as a
theoretical physicist who thinks about
the universe and the many worlds of
quantum mechanics and so forth
i'm often asked like what is the point
of this you know are you
are you making a better cell phone or
are you carrying cancer like why are you
doing this and i have my own answers but
as a mathematician who works on topology
category things like that you must also
get this so you what what is your do you
have a favorite answer to that kind of
question
sure i mean my my dad loves to ask me
what the practical applications are
about
the math i love to think about and uh i
think he knows that he's kind of
needling me because
you know that's just it's just not the
point for
all mathematicians i mean for some of
course it is you know there
are very um important
uses of mathematics to make the world a
better place but i guess a way that
mathematics can make the world a better
place is by making it a more interesting
place to
be a conscious being and that's how i or
that's what inspires me to be a
mathematician
yeah good no i think i i'm not gonna say
that's the right answer because like you
say
different people have different answers
but that's analogous to my answer when
people ask me about looking for the
higgs boson and
so many of my physics friends will say
like well it might someday inspire
a new technological something i'm like
no no number one no it won't
and number two that's not why we're
doing it we're doing it we want to find
out what's going on and
if there's a application someday that'll
be a benefit
the other preliminary question i wanted
to ask i just had a podcast episode a
couple of weeks ago about
the philosophy of mathematics and
you know there's realism versus
non-realism platonism
uh versus i don't know anti-platonism uh
i'm told that most working
mathematicians are platonists they think
of what they
study as in some sense real do you
do you know or care or have a take on
that debate
uh i certainly don't know as much about
it as some of your other guests but i
i agree with that instinct i mean
the things that i think about and i
dream about and i talk about with my
friends feel very real to me
and you know i don't expect that i'll
kind of trip over one on my walk to
campus but
you know they feel as real to me as i
mean as anything else i mean like
i guess as i understand it that you know
at a table that seems like a solid real
thing is not really
real either so um so yes i yeah i
subscribe to platonism
um well yeah i mean there's certainly
some structure to math right like we all
agree
given the axioms where we go and so
forth uh so there's something there i i
actually don't have a strong opinion one
way or the other that's why i'm
i'm quizzing people these days but
though actually i mean there's a
there's a philosophy of mathematics
that's maybe a little closer to the
point of view of category theory which
we'll get into later on
which goes by the name of structuralism
which uh
says that um you know what a
mathematical
object really is is determined by the
role that it plays
within mathematics so um
so for example uh you know you could ask
what are the natural numbers
you know 0 1 2 three four five and
uh a role that uh
the natural numbers play within
mathematics um i could
i could give it a fancy name i could say
they're the kind of universal discrete
dynamical system but essentially what
that means
is uh you know natural numbers are
something you can recursively define
functions on if you uh have
if you're trying to define a you know
sort of a sequence
of points or a sequence of real numbers
um
what you strategy you know fibonacci
sequence for instance is a famous
sequence one one two three five eight
thirteen twenty one thirty four uh the
relative terms
uh converge to the golden ratio it's uh
there's a lot of fun properties in
fibonacci but a strategy for defining a
sequence
is you define the first term in the
sequence or maybe the first few terms
and then you give a formula or a
strategy for producing the next term in
the sequence from the terms you have
previously and
the fact that recursion is possible is
telling us something very deep about the
role
that natural numbers play in mathematics
and so i guess i'm of the point of view
of like that's what the natural numbers
are they're sort of the thing that you
can recursively define
functions on um um how quite how that
fits with platonism isn't entirely clear
to me but yeah i don't know me neither i
did have a guest a while ago james
ladyman who's a philosopher who says
the same thing about physics he is a
structural
realist he thinks that what really
matters are the different structures not
the objects that we
uh attribute these structures to
relating between i don't know
great it sounds like he's a category
theorist so it could be
aren't we all our category theorists are
moving in that direction so we will get
to there but
i think that you had um as we were
talking about what to discuss here i
think you had a strategy that makes
perfect sense of starting with
topology because topology is something
everyone has heard of right i mean why
don't i
rather than trying to guess why don't
you tell us what you think the
definition of topology is that we could
all
get our hands on great uh so um topology
is the
study of spaces both um you know kind of
physical
geometrical spaces that we move in in
the world but also
spaces that you might imagine um that
you know have some resemblance to you
know euclidean space three dimensions
two dimensions one dimension but
uh are somehow more exotic
so um a topological space could be
um you know for instance the points on a
plane
is a as an example of a topological
space or you can imagine the points that
are on the surface
of a sphere so surface of a soccer ball
surface of the earth
or you can imagine the points that are
on the surface of a donut
you can imagine that you're an ant that
uh sort of walks around
a donut and um all the different
configurations that ant could be in
those describe points in a
topological space and then you can start
to compare what those
worlds are like um the topology is a
realm to do that can i just ask very
quickly
when mathematicians use the word space
obviously it doesn't
simply mean the three-dimensional space
in which we live what's the difference
between space
and set right uh so
if i wanted to define a topological
space
formally in mathematics i would start
with a set of points
so uh so if i wanted to
describe three-dimensional euclidean
space i would start
with the set of points which are
determined by three real coordinates
sort of a distance along the x-axis a
distance along the y-axis a distance
along the z-axis
so that's a a set of points so we can
think of them as the points in
three-dimensional
space but then what turns a set into a
topological space
is also a way to understand distances
between points or more generally
understand when points are nearby and
when
when points are far apart so so that
could be a function that tells you how
to compute the distance between
two points that's a metric space which
is an
important type of topological space or
there's a more abstract way to get at
the same thing in the absence of a
formula for distances okay
and so a line is a space
a circle is a space a sphere so
for mathematicians the sphere is just
the surface of the sphere right it's not
the interior like you said the
two-dimensional sphere is the surface of
the of the ball
um and then you could have like a 100
dimensional sphere or whatever so
there's a lot of spaces we have to play
with
you can have mobius bands so that's
that's a space that's kind of like
uh i mean it's kind of like a cylinder
so it's like the
toilet paper tube but imagine you cut
the toilet paper tube you know sort of
long ways from end to end so now you
have a
just a flat strip and then you twist it
and then glue it back together
so that is also a space it's
quite similar to the cylinder but it's
uh it's a non-orientable space it's
confusing in a mobius strip
whether you're on the inside or the
outside there's no way to decide that
whereas on
you know the toilet paper tube there's
the outside where the toilet paper goes
around and there's the inside which you
sort of
put on the roll or the holder so do you
have one of those klein bottle
sculptures
i have a klein bottle sculpture i i
don't but uh
right so a klein bottle is a one
dimension higher version of this and
what's interesting about the klein
bottle is uh
um well uh so it so it's a surface it's
kind of like
the surface of a sphere um let me
describe how you would build
a klein bottle so you um you can start
with a flat sheet of paper
you would glue two sides of the paper
together
so you're forming now a toilet paper
tube and then
uh so from there kind of a simpler
construction that isn't the klein bottle
is you could just
sort of stretch the toilet paper tube
and glue the end circles together and if
you
did that you would get a surface of a
donut shape
so so that's familiar the taurus we can
use the word doors it's okay okay we can
use the right torch so
if i want to get a klein bottle it's the
same idea i'm going to glue the two ends
of the toilet paper tube together
glue those two circular ends together
but i want to twist
the one so if i'm gluing if i'm walking
around
when i glue them together i'm sort of
zipping up the
going counterclockwise around one of the
circles and clockwise around the other
circle but i want to reverse the
orientation on one of the circles before
doing this
now you can't do this in
three-dimensional space so if if we were
in a fourth
dimension you could actually embed a
klein bottle into four-dimensional space
and do this construction but there are
um there are these toys that you you
should just everyone should just google
and
and they're these sorry glass versions
and what's fun about it is there's
some ambiguity between what uh space is
inside of a klein bottle and what is
outside so if you
you have a taurus like a glass donut you
could sort of fill it with jelly
and the jelly is inside the taurus it's
not outside you know until you bite it
you're not gonna get jelly everywhere
but if you have
one of these klein bottles you could try
and put you know jelly or let's say
kool-aid
inside the klein bottle and if you're
not careful if you sort of
flip it upside down and flip it right
side up again it's going to get all over
your desk because there's no inside and
outside
um yeah and this is the stock and trade
of topologists right so you
don't care so much about the individual
bumps and wiggles like
geometry cares about topology is more
loosey-goosey and what it cares about
exactly yeah very loosey-goosey and so
but the
the other thing to get on the table i
guess is that there are topological
spaces that we care about
well maybe they're inspired by real
physical situations but you might think
that well
physical space is three-dimensional and
we can have subsets of that
therefore you know there's some
topological spaces to think about but
not that many
but as you point out like there are
complicated situations where the space
of all possible configurations of
something is an interesting topological
space
yeah totally so i mean one of my uh
favorite sources of examples of
topological spaces are something called
configuration spaces
and these come up in robotics they come
up in in physics where they might be
called
state spaces and uh exactly as you point
out these can
get very high dimension very quick but
let me mention an example that's
small enough that we can dream about it
so you know imagine
you have a factory and there's a sort of
one-dimensional track on the
floor in the factory so there's a
there's a strip essentially
and you know maybe it's a kind of a
wheel or like a train track you can move
forward and backwards along that track
and we're going to have two robots
positioned on the track there's a red
robot
and a blue robot um so well
let's actually start with one robot so
if you wanted to if you had one robot on
a track
then you can describe its positions
um you know using just kind of a one one
dimension it's
it's like an interval you can have the
robot all the way at one end or all the
way at the other end or any place in
between it can move continuously
so this one dimensional interval is
describing the space of configurations
of that robot
so now let's put two robots on the the
track a red one and a blue one
and now um there's a space that
describes the configurations
of those two robots i mean you might
think it's a one-dimensional space
because you're still
right robots are still on this
one-dimensional track but actually
you know you should use kind of one
coordinate to keep track of where the
red robot is
and another coordinate to keep track of
where the blue robot is
and so that is describing the space
that's formed by taking a product of an
interval with itself in other words it's
a square
including the interior except the two
robots can't be in the same
spot you know one you know that if these
are physical robots
they can't collide into each other so
you have to remove a diagonal segment
from
that square and what you're left is with
these two
triangular components the bottom
triangle corresponds to the red robot
being on the right of the blue robot
and the top triangle corresponds to the
red robot being on the left
of the blue robot and so what's
interesting about the space what we can
see already by visualizing the
configuration space which is this square
with a diagonal removed from it
is that it's disconnected once you've
put your robots on the track
you're not going to be able to swap
their orientation
with respect to each other that's right
but uh
you know if you're designing the factory
you might say well that's a little bit
undesirable i don't have as much
flexibility and
improvement perhaps in the design
depending of course what you're trying
to do with these robots on this track is
you could make a circular track instead
of a
you know straight track and if you a
circle is also a one-dimensional
object you just sort of move around it
going clockwise there's kind of one
direction of motion
but if you had two robots on a circular
track then
what the way you describe their
configuration space is you would take
uh you know each robot is some arbitrary
point in the circle we have two circles
though so we take the product
of those two circles and this is fun to
think about that actually
the product of two circles corresponds
to the points on the surface of a torus
again right so so s1 cross s1 the
product of two circles are the points on
the torus
again the robots can't be on the same
point so you what you have to do is you
have to imagine you have the surface of
a taurus you built it by
gluing together your toilet paper tube
now you're going to make a diagonal cut
that uh it's a cut that goes
around sort of both loops and the torus
once so you
uh actually actually did this at home
last night to to test it and the way my
toilet paper tube was made
exactly exactly there so it was easy to
see that cutting
sort of a diagonal cut that moves once
around in both directions
and if you do that you're left with a
connected surface and that
corresponds to the idea that if you have
two robots on a circular track
they can really visit all configurations
there's no sort of left and right
anymore you can have them in any
position um
so anyway this is this is just sort of
baby baby examples of a really rich and
beautiful subject
some of the most difficult and important
decisions we make
involve choosing people whether it's
choosing a phd thesis advisor or
choosing a prospective spouse
or choosing who to hire for your company
i can't help you with the first two but
if you're looking to hire people i can
recommend
indeed indeed is the job site that makes
hiring
easy you can post your ad you can screen
candidates and
interview them all on indeed indeed
gives you tools like indeed
instant match giving you quality
candidates whose resumes
fits your job description immediately
and indeed
skills tests that on average reduces
hiring time by 27 percent
you can choose from more than 130 skills
tests
then add your must have requirements so
that you only pay for the applications
that meet them get started right now
with a free 75 dollar sponsored job
credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through june 30
terms and conditions apply
right because it's good because what
topologists care about are the features
that
uh don't change by like small
deformations of the space
so the fact that a space is in two
disconnected components like the
original example
versus just being one connected
component like the second example that's
the kind of thing that
gets topologists very excited right so
when i say circular track it could be an
oval track it could be a square track it
could be a hexagonal track from a
topologist those are all the same
the famous thing i bet many people have
heard that to a topologist
a coffee cup is the same as a donut
right because they're both tauruses
right right i mean that's not that's not
my favorite example because
uh so topologists have different notions
of when things are the same that we're
alluding to
and um one of the notions of sameness is
uh if two spaces are what's called
homeomorphic
and what homeomorphic means is that
there is a
sort of one-to-one correspondence
between the points and the space there's
a way
right you know there are two invertible
functions invertible continuous
functions that map all the points on one
space to the other and the other to the
one
and so if you have a solid taurus now
built out of clay
and you have a solid coffee cup
you can define one of these
homeomorphisms this sort of
one-to-one correspondence between the
points and the torus and the points in
the
um mug that are uh continuous so that
you're not tearing the surfaces apart or
adding new holes where there weren't
holes before that sort of thing
um so i mean it's true that topologists
uh consider uh taurus in a coffee mug to
be the same
but but for a like really kind of
obvious reason they're just so
so evidently the same but but um there's
another notion of sameness a weaker
notion of sameness that also comes up in
topology which is called
homotope equivalence and uh here are the
ideas two spaces are homotopic
equivalent if you can continuously
deform
one to another okay and so let me give
you some examples
so all of euclidean space you know
three-dimensional euclidean space is
homotopic equivalent to a single point
so you could imagine i think of this
homotopia equivalence as like the
reverse big bang
so you imagine three-dimensional
euclidean space you know so you have
let's imagine we have the origin point
so the center of the universe and then
all the other points in the universe i i
realize the universe is probably not
three-dimensional but like just
embarrassing also it doesn't have a
center but that's okay we're gonna
you're a matter of fact and orange
center but let's pretend there's a
center the universe and the universe is
three-dimensional
so in the reverse big bang what i'm
going to do is i'm going to continuously
move
all the points in the universe back in a
straight line to the center
of the universe to the origin and
they'll move kind of faster and slower
depending on how far
away they are so at time zero every
point is where it is and then at time
one they've all
crashed home into the the center of the
universe so that
that is uh describing a continuous
deformation that reveals that
three-dimensional euclidean space and
the point
are the same um so
so here's an example a sort of everyday
example of a homotopic equivalence that
feels
more fun let me let me just butt in
there because
so just to get it clear the the reason
why this is an interesting
example is because the point and
three-dimensional space
are homotopy equivalent they can be
continued one can be continuously
deformed to the other
but they're not homeomorphic because
there's not sort of an equal number of
points in them yeah right there's
uncountably infinitely many points in
three-dimensional space but there's one
point in one point space and
yeah so this is a cooler way more
destructive notion i mean dimensions
totally don't matter anymore you know
all
n-dimensional euclidean space is also
homotopic equivalent to a point
yeah um so an example an everyday
example that is kind of like that
is uh to a topologist a pair of pants
and a thong
are the same you can imagine a homotopic
equivalence that sort of
uh you know shrinks sort of vertically
i guess you know and just leaves the
thong from the pair of pants so
and this is the so the point is that
there are different ways of expressing
the idea of sameness depending on your
sort of level of focus on what you care
about
yeah totally totally and this is a this
is very pervasive in mathematics
uh you know mathematicians uh love
trying to understand the sense in which
things are the same and it's often a
pretty loose
sense yeah so i had a very very brief
career in fact as a hack topologist when
i was in graduate school and i needed to
calculate the homotopy of various things
that appear in particle physics because
we have these things called topological
defects
right which are very important from the
early universe none of the things i
calculated turn it out to be relevant to
the real world but you know that's
that's the risk that we take when we do
these things but it gets us into
you know so far it's been fun homotopy
you know smoothly deforming things into
each other but now we want to be a
little bit more rigorous about it
we want to characterize uh we want to
use this notion
of uh smoothly deforming one thing into
another to characterize the topology of
different
spaces right i mean is in some sense our
job to sort of
characterize all topological spaces
yeah exactly and a way to a classical
problem which is a good way to visualize
this is you can ask how many different
surfaces
are there you know sort of in this yeah
sort of very flexible sense so not
necessarily just uh so for instance is
uh we've described a few different
surfaces there's the
sort of surface of a sphere there's a uh
surface of a torus
um you can have many hold the taurus was
the donut shape you can imagine having
many hold doughnuts or like
you know you're baking a tray of donuts
but you've put them too close to each
other and so
they've all kind of congealed and
there's you know one donut with three
holes in it you know that's another
surface and uh there's a classification
question you know how can we tell
that these spaces are really different
i mean they seem different perhaps maybe
i'm giving away yeah now they're my
intuition but they seem different you
know how but how do we prove that
they're different because we've seen
that these wildly different spaces
are in some sense the same yeah so
so how do we do that right so
yeah so so the idea is i mean this this
is a hard question to answer
geometrically because
um just because you can't imagine a
continuous deformation of one space to
the other doesn't mean it doesn't exist
so a strategy is to
bring algebra into the story somehow and
give a way to assign a number or
uh some other kind of algebraic
structure to a
topological space and uh
if in a way that would give the same
answer if the spaces were homotopic
equivalent
so uh so the homology groups or homotopy
groups that uh
there are various different uh
constructions you can do and it's
it's easy to prove that if the spaces
have continuously deformable into each
other
they'll produce the same invariance and
so if you happen to get different
invariants then you know that they were
different
right so actually let me go ahead
well i was gonna i can give an example
of this yes exactly do that
so um what i'm going to try and argue
for you
is that the surface of a sphere so the
surface of a soccer ball
is a different space than the surface of
a donut so a taurus and a sphere are
different topological spaces
and just to make sure we're imagining
these spaces again you know imagine
you're an
ant walking around the surface of a
sphere
that's one space the different positions
the ant could be
or you can imagine an ant walking around
the surface of a doughnut not the
interior in either case just the same
not the interior in either case right
the ant
the ant can't eat the donut or eat this
is sort of stuck on the surface um
and it can't like jump off either it's
you know okay
so um right so uh
the invariant that i'm gonna use to
prove that these are different is
something called the fundamental group
that is uh it's a
and what it's counting essentially so in
each it's for convenience i'm going to
pick
a point on each of these spaces these
spaces are connected so picking a point
is not
a big deal so pick whichever one you
want we'll take the north pole on the
sphere and any point at all on the torus
and what the fundamental group
is going to calculate is the number of
essentially different ways
that the ant can walk from this home
base point
walk around on the surface and come back
to the home base point
right the the subtlety there as i said
the number of essentially different ways
so i mean there are uncountably
infinitely many ways an ant can walk
around these surfaces but what i'm
asking are
are they essentially different and so
let's set aside the sphere example for
now let's let's start by thinking about
the surface of the donut
okay so an example of uh two ways that
are essentially different
is we can imagine starting at our home
base point
and walking let's say in a
counterclockwise direction
around the loop that goes through the
sort of donut hole if you put a donut
hole inside the donut that's
you can imagine walking it's sort of
been a vertical the short way around
basically the short the short way around
great um so that's one way the ant could
walk
or the ant could walk let's say
tracing the same trajectory but going in
reverse orientation
going backwards rather than forwards
so those uh those are fundamentally
different and what i mean by fundamental
different is there's no way to
continuously deform
the first trajectory into the second
trajectory
while staying on the surface of the
donut if i could sort of
slice through um you know where the
dough bit of the donut is
i could do that i could sort of cut
cut through the bit that's not on the
surface but that's not allowed so
um walking in the surface once the ant
decides it's going clockwise
rather than counterclockwise it's um
those are different choices that the ant
can make in fact they're
they're homotopically inequivalent right
so because you cannot
right that's continuously deformed one
into another right and there are
what's what's cool is uh you can
actually enumerate all of the different
choices
so another different trajectory the ant
could take is it could walk the long way
around so let's say staying on the top
and going clockwise or going
counterclockwise or it can do some sort
of comment
combination where it loops you know some
number of times through the center
circle while also
traversing the long way around
and there's a way to enumerate all of
these
essentially different trajectories what
you need are two different integers
essentially one integer that's
describing
the number of times you go in a
clockwise or counterclockwise
direction around the short loop and then
another integer is describing the number
of ways to go
counterclockwise or clockwise depending
on whether it's positive or negative
around the long
loop and you can prove that uh this pair
of integers
enumerates all possible trajectories
right
right so on a on
us the sphere um it's actually quite a
lot
simpler so if you have you can imagine
any
path the ant might take on the surface
of a sphere from the north pole to the
north pole
kind of wandering around any which way
and um
you could kind of shrink that trajectory
in a continuous way
um sort of so that it gets smaller and
smaller and smaller so if
it in fact goes all the way to the south
pole maybe it shrinks a little bit so it
only goes to the
equator and then maybe it shrinks a
little more so it stays north of the
tropic of cancer and so on and so forth
and
eventually all of the trajectories are
deformable to just the ants sitting at
the north pole and never moving
at all so there there's only one
trajectory that the ant can make and
that's the proof somehow that these two
spaces are not
the same which is wonderful because you
know it took us on a little journey i
actually want to dig into this because
um on the one hand we're not surprised
that the sphere and the torus are
topologically different but it was a bit
of an effort there
to actually show it right even that case
where we had things under control
and in doing that you know you stumble
across you so you ask the question
how many different ways are there to
sort of do this path that returns to
itself a loop right a closed circle
in in this space and in the case of the
taurus
you you just uncovered uh this pair of
integers
the number of times you go around the
short way the number of times you go
around the long way
and integers not to not to get too fancy
about it now that's
algebra that's not geometry or topology
or anything like
roughly speaking mathematicians are
either geometers and they like space
or or they're algebraists and they like
equations right
but an algebraic structure appeared here
somehow
right i think you know this is just the
tale of complexity in the modern world
like every everybody has to be
everything these days so
even if you really your heart isn't with
geometry you have to use some algebra
so well i want to i want to just take
advantage of your being here to dig into
this a little bit more i mean sure
the the we asked this question about
how many ways you can draw a circle
roughly speaking in the taurus
um and there's a lot of ways but then
there's this hidden structure in that if
you have
a circle going around once in one
direction
and another circle just doing the same
thing you can add them together
in some sense right and that's the
beginning of algebra am i am i too
dramatic there
yeah that's exactly right so uh a more
um i mean i've described this in
describing the fundamental group i said
you know let's imagine we have a home
base point uh where they and we're gonna
consider
the ant walking in these little loops
from the home base to the home base
but it's actually maybe more natural to
not have a home base point because
uh you know i don't i don't know where
it would be on the surface of a taurus
for instance
so um another way to think about this
sort of algebraic structure is you can
imagine
an ant walking from any point p on the
surface to any other point
q on the surface it you know takes some
path
and then later you know maybe the ant is
tired and takes a nap
and then later it wakes up and then it
walks from the point q to some other
point
r and what you're referring to is you
could then compose those two paths
compose those two
uh trajectories and then get a path
directly from p to r so if you can walk
from p to q and walk from q to r you can
compose those two walks and get from p
to r
and that's the beginning so this is a
composition operation
on the paths and the surface of
a taurus or on any space paths in any
space and
really the sort of invariant that more
exactly describes the algebra that's
hidden in the geometry
is something called the fundamental
groupoid or the fundamental infinity
groupoid which is
not a a group which is a type of
mathematical object we teach
undergraduates um but an sort of
infinite dimensional analog of a group
an infiniti groupoid which is a
you know sort of frontier of research
level mathematics right
i think that it look if if people are
going to listen to this entire podcast
episode
i want them to come away knowing what an
infinity groupoid is i think that's
going to be something that they'll be
able to impress their friends with at
cocktail parties and so forth so
you but to go very slowly to get there
you know you mentioned the fundamental
group
which is the collection of the circles
we started with so what's a group
right so a group is uh
um i mean a way to i mean
this like it there's there's this um
uh there's this metaphor of the blind
men and the elephant and
you know somebody's holding somebody's
touching the uh
trunk somebody's touching one of the
legs somebody's touching the tail and
have a completely different perspective
of it and that's that's how i'm thinking
about groups so it's like really hard to
know know how to start
but um you know a group
in this context is a set here it's the
collection of all different
loops that uh ant could take walking
through
some space um together with a
composition
operation so it's performing one loop
and then following it by another loop
that can be understood as a loop even
though you come back
through the center it's still a loop um
and then satisfying some you know sort
of very natural
axioms so if you're walking along a loop
you could always reverse your trajectory
and
walk back in the other direction and
that's an undoing somehow of the process
so every element in a group has an
inverse that if you compose with it it
gets back to
sort of where you started and a few sort
of simple axioms like that
so it's kind of a it's a stripped-down
version
of you know the integers or something
like that right where the integers you
can add them together so
the integers are an example of a group
right right
integers with addition is an example
with a different group absolutely
that's right matrices with
multiplication is an example of a group
matrices with addition is an example of
a group
so i have to say something about the
dimensions to make those examples work
but
okay and the physicists love group
theory
because symmetries are a group right
like rotations and translations and
things like that
yeah absolutely so another perspective
on groups if we sort of move around the
elephant
is uh a group is an asthmaticization
of uh the symmetries of an object so um
so or the different configurations that
an object might be so let me let me
explain what a symmetry is so
um so imagine you have a twin mattress
and you know that you're supposed to
kind of flip your your mattress
occasionally because i guess it's good
for the life of the mattress
and so you might wonder like how many
different ways are there to flip the
mattress how many different
configurations could the mattress be in
and um
well it's the mattress one option is
whatever the mattress is when you start
it
um then you could uh sort of rotate it
head to toe so you're sort of
switching the head and the toe but the
top stays the same that's
one move uh you could also
um flip it uh
sort of side to side so i'm keeping the
head at the head and the toe at the toe
but i'm switching the top and the bottom
yep um or you could combine those two
operations and the effect of this is the
head is now where the toe was and the
toes were the head and the the
top and bottom surfaces has also flipped
so a group is recording on the one hand
the four different
positions that the mattress could be in
but also how these different flipping
operations that i described composed to
each other
so each of those flips
is an order two element of the group
meaning if you perform the same move
twice you get the mattress back
to where you started if you do any two
different
of the flips you'll get the third one
which is not a typical property of a
group but it's special to this one which
is
goes by the name the klein 4 group
this group does not have a generator
meaning that
there's not one operation you can do
over and over again that will take you
all the way
through the group and this is why it's
hard to remember how to flip your
mattress because
you have to remember sort of how you
flipped it last month so you don't uh
just do the same operation and again and
get back to where you were the month
before
yeah so the integers do have a generator
you just add one and then you can get
all the integers either by doing that or
undoing it
or add one or negative one you get all
the way through everything so yes the
integers are cyclic group
um which have a single generator
absolutely but klein four group is not
uh right so the integers maybe to people
who are not group theory
aficionados are a nice little paradigm
but it's important that groups can be
very different so this is a finite group
the this uh mattress flipping group
right it's only how many elements are
there in the mattress yeah four elements
okay
yeah yeah all right and there's um so i
mean these these groups are super cool
and
uh you know really tell you something
profound about geometry so uh
you might have heard of the platonic
solids which are the
um the three-dimensional figures that
you can get by
gluing together regular uh
two-dimensional figures
so a regular two-dimensional figure is
like a triangle
or a square or a pentagon or a hexagon
where all the
sides have the same length all the
angles are the same and so on and so
forth
and you know there are infinitely many
of these because there's a heptagon and
an octagon and a nonagon you know for
any
natural number n you can get a plane
figure with n
sides so you might wonder how many of
these regular
platonic solids are you know how many
different
shapes you can get by gluing together
say triangles or gluing together squares
or gluing together
pentagons or you know gluing together
hexagons maybe
and um you can prove in fact that there
are only
finitely many in fact there are five of
them um using group
theory by studying the symmetries
the sort of orthogonal groups the smit
or the special orthogonal groups that
describe the different configurations of
these hypothetical shapes before even
knowing they exist you can limit
the possible configurations um but
clearly that's not what plato did
i don't know maybe some somewhere like
buried in plato's
intuition but another fun fact is so the
five
there's something called the tetrahedron
which is built from triangles and then
there's the cube which is
that's the most familiar one built from
squares then there's the octahedron also
built from triangles
and then the dodecahedron and the
icosahedron
and even though i named five things in a
sense there's kind of only three of them
because
there's this duality relationship
between the platonic solids which you
might have seen if you take
a cube so it's got uh four
so it's sorry it's spaces are uh squares
there are six of them
and they are glued together along twelve
different edges and there are eight
corners and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to build a new
platonic solid by replacing each of the
corners by a face
and each face by a corner and what you
get in that
just by kind of connecting everything up
is an octahedron
so one of the other platonic solids and
so there's a duality relationship
between the cube and the octahedron and
also between the dodecahedron and the
icosahedron and be that between the
tetrahedron and itself
and those are reflected by their
symmetry groups so because of this
duality relationship
the symmetry group that describes the
configurations of the cube
is the same isomorphic two the same
shape as this
symmetry group of the octahedron and so
on
anyone who played dungeons and dragons
knows about the platonic solids because
they have the dice but they don't know
about the duality relations so now
that's that's good that's something else
that they that they'll
have in their bag now i'm only going to
do this at great risk but i figure like
all right why
while we've talked about groups why
don't we also explain
rings and fields to the audience since
these are the other sort of algebraic
structures that mathematicians love to
throw around
yeah absolutely so uh i mean what's
funny is
you know after a while you kind of
forget that these terms refer to other
things so i mean
you know when i say field i mean i
definitely think about the mathematical
field before i remember that's like also
the thing that's out the window but
right so uh a group um is
describing a setting where you have you
know collection of objects and you have
one composition operation to combine
them together so if we have the integers
we can think about addition if you add
two integers
you get another integer but
you know we there are other binary
operations on the integers that come up
you know multiplication for instance
and a ring is a setting where you have
two operations an addition operation or
an addition-like operation and a
multiplication like
operation and they
interact in ways that are sort of
familiar
for the integers so if i you can
understand
there's a distributivity property that
says if i add
two integers together and then i
multiply by something it's the same as
multiplying first and then
adding and there are a few axioms like
that
so what's cool about i mean you might
ask like why do we bother we like
everybody knows what the integers are
why do i need
this abstract concept of a ring and
that's a totally fair question but a
really fun
or it's kind of interesting fact is
there's a very deep analogy between the
integers
and polynomials um so
so a polynomial is like this this is
sort of the thing that you would
meet in a high school algebra class so
you have a
a variable x an indeterminate variable x
and then you
can form a polynomial by sort of adding
up x's and multiplying x's and then
throwing in real numbers
as the coefficients so a polynomial
might be
like 5x minus
5x plus i don't know 17 x squared
plus pi x cubed because we can have real
numbers as coefficients
minus 3. you know so that's that's a
polynomial
in a single variable x and
polynomials also form a ring if you have
two polynomials you can add them
together
you can multiply them there's sort of
rules for doing this that you might have
learned in a
high school algebra class and those ring
the ring of polynomials
uh with coefficients in a field which
we'll get to what a field is later on
coefficients in the real numbers and the
ring of integers
are very are very quite similar as rings
they're both
uh they have a division algorithm um you
can do sort of long division with
polynomials like with rings
all the ideal elements are principles
and um so
i mean that's the sort of thing that's
of interest to mathematicians or these
kind of deep analogies between
structures that are superficially quite
different
well and what's the difference between a
ring and a field because they're kind of
similar
right so a field is uh like a ring it
has
two binary operations um but
uh if we go back to the ring of integers
there's a pretty big difference between
the addition rule and the multiplication
rule so if i uh
in in that every addition every element
has an additive
inverse so if i pick my favorite integer
you know 17
there's another integer negative 17 that
when i add them together i get 0
which is the identity for the addition
operation
but that doesn't work for multiplication
if i pick my favorite integer again 17
there's no integer i can multiply
uh 17 by to get back to one which is the
multiplicative identity
right so that's what distinguishes a
ring where you don't necessarily have
multiplicative inverses from a field in
a field you do
have an inverse to both the
multiplication and the addition
operation
you're sort of assuming you're not
trying to divide by zero that never
quite works
so things like the rational numbers
which throw in these multiplicative
inverses or the real numbers
are uh fields in addition to bean rings
and
does the existence of the number zero
get you in trouble because uh
it doesn't have yeah so in a field you
have to
treat zero as a kind of special case so
in a field you have to your zero and
your one can't be the same
otherwise uh the whole thing kind of
collapses and
zero will not have a multiplicative
inverse but every other element has to
got it okay and so what we started we
started this little journey this little
side track because
we were thinking about the taurus and
its topology
and we found that the space of all the
little loops the ant could walk on
formed a group uh are there examples
where
we associate rings or fields with
topological invariants
uh that's a good question
i don't know that that's commonly done
and i think the reason is that groups
are just so rich
you know um but uh
you know a single group will not capture
the full
data of a topological space i mean
really what you have to do is have
introduce lots of different groups that
are measuring lots of different things
so the the fundamental group tells you
about uh sort of
loops in the space and whether you can
uh
if you sort of walk along a circular
path in the space can you
fill that in with a disk um you know
could you
uh i guess i don't know how to say it
any better than that because
you know can you contract you know if
yeah if you have sort of a wire ring is
there
could you put sort of a soap bubble on
it somehow so that the surface of the
soap bubble lives within the space that
you were
talking about so that's that's not
possible if you're walking the short way
around on a taurus because the soap
bubble would have to kind of cut through
the dough and that's
that's not on the surface but it is on
the surface of a sphere you could just
kind of
you know paint uh paint over the disc
so that's measuring this kind of
one-dimensional holes i guess is the
the area that's bounded by a
one-dimensional sphere but as we
mentioned there are kind of spheres in
higher
dimensions so you could ask if you have
a balloon
inside your surface can that be filled
in with sand
sort of staying within right right the
surface and that's a two-dimensional
analog of the same question and there's
a
question like that in all positive
integer dimensions
and um that family of groups
describes the full homotopy type of a
space a single group does not but if you
have this
sort of infinitely many groups it does
one of the things that i say just very
casually
to people who are not mathematicians is
that you might think that mathematicians
spend all their time thinking about
mathematical objects like spheres or
tauruses or whatever but really they're
thinking about maps
between the different objects so i guess
uh it's fair to say that first thing the
fundamental group is maps from
circles into the space you care about
and then there's the map
the set of maps from spheres and then
the set of maps
from three spheres and it clearly
generalizes to infinite numbers
yeah absolutely absolutely but there's
something special about the groups
uh you don't get fields or rings which
have two different
binary operations on them i guess the
last thing that i have in that in that
angle is
is there something special about fields
and rings that have two binary
operations that it's worth stopping
there can we define
three binary operations on a set and
make hyper rings or something like that
uh
sure i mean you know algebra is a very
flexible subject
and um you know to define what an
algebra is in full generality you need
you know kind of the collection of
elements that you're considering and
then you can specify
arbitrarily many operations with
arbitrary arities and you can specify
arbitrarily many rules between them and
you know the subject
of universal algebra invites you to
consider um examples like that
let's invite uh listeners in the
audience who are
inclined in that direction to follow
study universal algebras but we're going
to go back
to the topology and the groups the the
uh you see made a statement there i just
want to make sure that i get it clear
um if i if i figure out
the set of all ways that i can map uh
circles and spheres and
three-dimensional spheres etc into a
space
i have i've not specified its
topology completely but i've specified
its homotopy
type topology completely which is a
slightly weaker thing is that right
that's that's right yeah okay so do we
know the answer to the general question
of how to
completely specify the topology of a
space
right uh so a classical the classical
approach to that and it's kind of a
tautology
but um let's imagine it's a theorem as
opposed to a topology i mean for
if you restrict to sort of well-behaved
spaces it's a theorem and if you
take general spaces it's kind of a
tautology but um so
the classical approach to this is
exactly what you're saying so you
describe
what's called the um sort of nth
homotopic group as
the collection of maps from the n sphere
into
your space and then because it's a group
you need a composition operation which
uh for two spheres i can describe
the composition so if i have a map
from a two-dimensional sphere
into a space and a map from another
two-dimensional sphere into the space
and these these maps are based
so they uh there's the kind of north
pole and they send them to the same
point in the space
um you can imagine taking another
two-dimensional sphere
and then collapsing the equator to a
single point so if you had a balloon
and you collapse the points on the
equator you sort of squeeze at them
carefully so it doesn't pop and so now
you have a single point now what you
look like is something that's called a
bouquet of spheres it's
sort of two different spheres that are
glued together
along the point where the equator used
to be and you could sort of
map from that into the space because you
have two different maps into the space
that
uh have a common point and um sort of
the
combination of that operation is how you
define the composition here
okay good and so there's an analog of
that in all dimensions so
this is the classical approach to saying
what is a space algebraically what are
some algebra stuff that tell you
everything that you would want to know
about the homotope type of the space
but a modern approach goes back to the
idea of the fundamental group um
and but replaces it by uh something
called the fundamental
infinity groupoid and since i promised i
would tell you exactly listeners what an
infinity group
is let me let me do it now so um
so i i like this because this feels like
a kind of much more natural way to
describe the space
and uh again the the fundamental group
word
um depending on your point of view
either it's a theorem or it's a
tautology
really does capture the full homotopic
type of the space so what is it
it's um so it's some algebraic structure
where i'm going to start with the set
of all points in the space so i've
forgotten the topology i've forgotten
about distances and stuff i'm just
remembering the set of points
okay uh you know because in algebra i
have sort of sets and
stuff i don't have uh geometry so i just
remember the set of the points in the
space
then what i'm going to throw in is the
data of every possible
path between any points in the space
this is going to be a very big
thing by the way so so we re recover now
every possible path that an ant could
take between points in the space
and by the way composition i mean i got
to say that mathematicians use the word
data in a different sense than
physicists use it
oh yeah i mean all of our sets are
infinite it's fine and
no problems when you say like the data
of a path you mean whatever information
is required to specify that path among
the space of all the paths
right so we have all the points in the
space we have all the paths in the space
now when we were thinking about
paths before when we were talking about
the taurus we were talking about
you know well we only want to consider
paths up to being essentially
essentially the same sort of
continuously deformable we're not doing
that here we're literally remembering
every single path every path has a
distinct path
good but we are also going to remember
data of these continuous
deformations so there's a notion of path
between
paths if a path is a map from an
interval into the space
this is a continuous map from a square
into the space an
interval times an interval is a square
and
so a map from a square into space can be
understood as a path between paths sort
of where one edge goes as one path where
the other edge goes is the other path
and then the sort of other direction the
other dimension is giving the
kind of path between paths so we're
going to remember all of those as well
all of these
paths between paths so these are called
homotopies and then
there's no reason to stop at two
dimensions so we could take three
intervals producted together that's a
cube
remember all of those maps into the
space these are paths between paths
between paths
and then we could take paths between
paths between paths between paths pass
between pass between pass between pass
between fast and all the way up and that
goes to infinity that's the infinity
groupoid
so that data i mean this feels like it's
maybe not an improvement but somehow
yeah it's something somehow that
algebraic structure
uh um you know both uh
describes the full homotopic type of a
space which is a useful way to think
about it but also
invites you to imagine a generalization
to a different world
that's further removed from the geometry
where you can imagine some of these
paths are no longer invertible anymore
these are sort of one-way
paths okay you know you you might not be
able to go backwards for
whatever reason and this is now the
world of infinite dimensional category
theory and that's really where i work
so well so which brings up a couple
there's a couple things i just got to
clean up there you were on a roll so i
just wanted to let you keep going
so one thing is just to remind folks
when you talked about
the path between two paths right the
the cube sorry the square that was a map
into it
that that path between two paths might
not exist if the if the two paths are
not homotopically equivalent that there
won't be
any path between them so there's some
structure in the space of what
pads between paths exist right by what's
present and what's absent that's a
beautiful way to say it
great and the other one was this is a
little bit off topic but
when you did the um explanation of the
sphere
and you squeezed it down at the equator
to get the bouquet not only is the
language very beautiful but
the visualization is very compelling and
one one thing that always gets asked
how do you visualize the infinity
groupoid is that something that uh
is necessary for you to do do you
approximate infinity by two
or is there some other trick uh it's
hard
i don't know i don't know i mean you you
sort of imagine a little piece of it at
a time and then
i don't know um yeah it's hard okay
that's fair
completely fair i i i basically give the
same answer i say you don't
you know you do the two-dimensional or
three-dimensional examples you can get
but
at some point you have to trust uh the
equations you're pushing around
and i don't think we've quite elaborated
the difference between a group and a
group boyd
right so the the difference between a
group is uh
so the example of a fundamental group
the elements of the group are actually
the loops
themselves we've kind of fixed as
priorly given data the
home base point for the ant and then the
only
further data we record are the the loops
in the space
so in a group void you don't fix
a base point you allow different base
points so the different points on the
surface of
or in the space and uh now so now you
have kind of two levels of data you have
the
collection of different points and then
you also have the paths between the
different points
okay is this is this i mean outside of
the world of topology and homo topi
is is uh are there groupoids i mean
groups
physicists use groups all the time right
sg3 cross su-2 cross u1 is the symmetry
group of the standard model of particle
physics
we've we never use the word groupoid
unless like we're secretly
mathematicians so
just in the abstract sense is there a
difference yeah sure
so your groups are all automorphism
groups of some
object right and it's a fixed object so
you know you're thinking about
automorphisms of r3 or automorphisms of
r4 or sort of r3 with a chosen
orientation or something like that so
your groups were all automorphism groups
of a fixed object
in a group word you have different
objects so there's not just one object
anymore there are different objects and
it's exactly the many object analog of a
group
okay i see that's not so bad and
automorphism is just a map from a space
to itself
is that right yeah okay good good yeah
yeah sorry
so we all know what automorphisms are
among our friends okay now of course
so then okay good sorry there's a lot of
clarifying questions but then let's get
back to the punch line here
the infinity groupoid uh
the sort of topological sense of all the
different paths
that we can map into um the space and
the paths between the paths and paths
between the paths of paths
so if we knew the infinity group weight
of a space we would know what
everything everything i mean well
everything if you only care about the
space up to homotopy
i mean if you're willing to say that n
dimensional euclidean space is the same
as a point there's no difference
whatsoever
then yes you know everything about the
space now i mean if you care about
geometry
or dimension or things like that then
you know this is not the right
point of view but that's okay but for
the taurus when you said
you know let's calculate the fundamental
group and we noticed that
it looked like so for the sphere the
fundamental group was just trivial just
one element
uh for the taurus it's two copies of the
integers
so it's basically two integers you just
give me is there
how do i even express uh what the
infinity groupoid of a space
is uh
right so let me move back to the sphere
because of the two sphere because it's a
little easier to describe here
so um if we're thinking about the loops
in the two sphere or the paths in the
two sphere there's kind of nothing
interesting to say if you have any two
points
on the sorry the two sphere is the
ordinary sphere if you have any
two points on a sphere you can connect
them by a path and there's a sense in
which all paths are the same you could
continuously
deform any path from x to y into any
other path from x to y
but now if we think about these
two-dimensional paths between paths
there are
fundamentally different ones and this is
really surprising so
in one dimension all paths are somehow
the same on the sphere but in two
dimensions
uh paths can be quite different so um
so if i want to think about paths
between paths and so i should
fix the two paths first so um let's
start at the
let's start at the north pole and the
south pole so these will be paths from
the north pole to the south pole and one
of the paths i want to take
is the international date line so
somewhere through the pacific ocean
and the other path i want to take is the
prime meridian which is i don't know
it's through england or something like
that
okay somewhere else so right so there's
the greenwich one and the pacific ocean
so those are both paths from the north
pole to the south pole
now a path between paths is a continuous
map from
a square onto the surface of the earth
that sends
one edge to the prime meridian and the
other edge to the
international date line and one of them
is the one that would cover
asia that would go east from the prime
meridian to the international date line
and the other one is the one that would
cover
the new world so go west uh
and um those are fundamentally different
in the sense that there is no
three-dimensional path no path between
paths between paths
that uh continuously deforms the one to
the other if you could pass through the
core
of the earth you could do that but we're
we have to stay in the surface it's not
allowed
so um in this sense the fundamental
group
or the fundamental group or the sort of
one-dimensional thing does not describe
everything that's going on on the
surface of the sphere but once we allow
these higher dimensional things
um we do get everything and it's your is
the kind of day job that you're
involved in more actually calculating
the fundament the infinity groupoid of
this or that or is it more
proving theorems about properties of
infinity group words
right it's so that's a great question
because those are both very active areas
there are a lot of researchers working
on both
both problems i don't do the
calculations myself they're
very hard you know i do kind of the
theory side but some of my colleagues
work on the calculations i'm sure it
makes everyone feel good that you don't
really do the hard part you're just
doing the simple part of moving
theorems about infinity group points
right and it also this discussion is
wonderful because
it does you know beneath the surface in
the language that you use in the way you
talk about it uh
the role of the maps between the
different spaces really shines through
you know you know just think of all the
spaces you can invent and all the
different ways you can map them
in in some sense and that sneaks us up
into the topic of category theory which
is not really our focus here but i don't
wanna
i don't wanna like leave the audience
completely uh bereft of category theory
while we're here
so how do we get from topology to
category theory
sure um i mean again there's lots of
different
roots in but maybe the one that's most
relevant to this conversation
and this is kind of back to this uh
back to the conversation and philosophy
that we started off with is
um so the fundamental theorem and
category theory
or somehow that that's expressing the
core philosophy of category theory this
thing called the unita lemma says that
if you have
any sort of mathematical object it could
be a topological space
or it could be a vector space or it
could be a ring or it could be a field
or whatever
any sort of mathematical object you can
understand
everything that you want to know about
it by considering
the other objects of that same type so
other spaces or other rings or other
fields
and the maps between them so
right so what this is saying in the case
of spaces is that if you have
uh unknown space x and you're trying to
understand that space so we don't know
sort of what its dimensions are what its
points are we don't know anything about
it
um a theorem in category theory the
janeta lama says that you can completely
characterize your unknown space
by considering the other spaces so all
these spheres and tori
and other surfaces and whatever in all
dimensions and then the continuous maps
from that into your space
x well okay what's cool about that
result so we
were using this idea in topology already
to understand spaces
but what's cool is it's completely
independent of the mathematical context
so the same theorem is true for rings
you can understand
a ring by thinking about other rings and
the ring homomorphisms between them you
can understand a group by thinking about
other groups and the group homomorphisms
between them
this works in any mathematical context
whatsoever
it's again a little bit uh related to
some ideas in physics that we should
always be talking about
relations between different things
rather than intrinsic essences
of things themselves so yeah absolutely
absolutely and and why is this called
category theory like
let's just bite the bullet and tell
people what a category is maybe sure so
i mean a category is kind of like a very
general template for a mathematical
theory so
barry mazur has this metaphor it's like
something with uh
nouns and verbs so a category is given
by a collection of objects these are the
nouns
and what you should think of here are
like all the rings all the possible
rings so the integers and the rationals
and the polynomials and
matrices and blah blah so all the rings
um
and then you also have the sort of
functions between them so in the case of
rings these would be functions that
respect the
addition and multiplication laws in the
case of spaces these would be continuous
functions
and sort of that totality of information
the objects like the spaces and the
functions the continuous functions or
maps between them and their composition
and so on that's
a category and what's great about this
is
every word you say makes perfect sense
and at the end i'm left not quite
knowing
what the implications of these ideas are
i mean that's where
that's the devil being the details right
you've ascended to this platonic realm
of
of wonderful abstraction where there's
just things and maps between them
so how do you what's the usefulness
what's the cashing out of this what is
the
free market value of a good category
theory right so
um i mean one nice thing about category
theory is you can just say when two
categories are the same
in a essential sense so there's a notion
of equivalence between categories and
i'll give you my favorite example
so um there's a
category whose objects are vector spaces
which are
um something that are kind of
fundamental in in sort of modern quantum
physics so
a vector space is like a you know
collection of vectors with vector
addition and scalar multiplication
and then the the sort of transformations
between vector spaces are called linear
transformations so there's so this is
kind of a bread and butter
category objects or vector spaces uh the
maps are transformations which are some
sort of functions between these vector
spaces
now there's another category that's kind
of a lot simpler to define
so the objects in this category are just
natural numbers
so they're i know exactly how many
objects there are each natural number is
an object there are no other objects
that's it
and now i need to say sort of what an
transformation
natural numbers are zero one two three
the positive zero one
negative integers yeah absolutely okay
so so now i need to say what a
sort of transformation or what an arrow
is from
one number let's say five to another
number eight
and what it is is it's going to be an
eight by five matrix okay
um so to make something a category i
need to tell you about the objects and
the
arrows between them and that's what i've
done the natural numbers are the objects
the matrices are the arrows
but you also need a composition law so i
need a way to take a
five by eight matrix and an eight by
seven matrix and produce a five by seven
matrix
um but there's a thing for that it's
called matrix multiplication
it's an operation that's satisfies the
axioms of category
so those are two very different sounding
categories on the one hand i have this
like
very abstract comp you know very large
thing of all vector spaces and all
linear transformations between them and
then on the other hand i have this kind
of toy category with natural numbers and
matrices
and those categories are equivalent so
in other words you can think of the
natural number as a stand-in for
a vector space the number five
corresponds to five dimensional
euclidean space i was going to guess
that i promise yes yeah
and you can think of uh matrix as a
stand-in for linear transformation so if
you have
vector spaces and you choose a basis
then you can use those bases to
get a matrix of numbers that encodes the
the full data
of the linear transformation and um so
in a mathematics department we often
teach linear algebra in kind of two
different tracks there's a sort of
computational linear algebra if you're
going to be
you know the next founder of google you
need to learn how to use do these matrix
operations and you'll take that sort of
course
um or there's a theoretical linear
algebra that's
you know taken maybe by more math majors
and
um this on the ground the subjects feel
very different because one you're
learning a lot about matrices and
reduction and operations and then the
other you're learning this theory about
linear independence and bases and so on
and so forth but it's the same subject
because they're these are equivalent
categories okay that's that is actually
a very good example of like a little
useful bit of insight that you get from
thinking this way
so just i know that this has sort of
already been said by you but let me try
to say it again to drive home this
notion of a category
to people who don't use it as a bread
and butter because when you say a vector
space
uh let's just imagine let's
optimistically imagine everyone knows
what a vector space is right they have
in their mind
x y axes and little vectors so a vector
space
is itself a collection of things right
the vectors there's an infinite number
of vectors in the vector space
but the category is of vector spaces so
the individual
elements of the category are the whole
vector space a two-dimensional vector
space a three-dimensional vector space
et cetera
and you're thinking about the maps
between vector spaces
and then extra maps between the set of
all vector spaces and the set of all
integers and things like that so it gets
pretty
unvisualizable pretty quickly but that's
why you get paid the big bucks
well the visual is you're you're sort of
zooming out you're really taking a
bird's-eye view of
of mathematics you're um you know that
the objects that
uh you know group theorists would study
are really just uh
little atoms inside of the category of
all groups and what's fun is if you're a
category theorist or a higher
dimensional category theorist really the
categories of themselves become very
small so
in my work i zoom out one other level
and i think about categories whose
objects are categories inside those
categories are things like the category
of vector spaces and then the
vector space is an actual vector space
which has uncountably infinitely many
vectors in it as you point out so and so
at what point do we get to the infinity
categories there's an infinity group
there must be an infinity category right
uh yeah sure
i mean um yeah
uh you know as every
every decade mathematicians invent more
complicated
objects to study and the universe is
where those objects live are
uh categories with more dimensions of
morphisms between them and those are
these infinity
categories i mean just knowing that can
you foresee what was going to be
invented in the next
decade like what is the obvious thing to
like draw more arrows between
yeah i mean what i'm hoping happens in
the future is that we change our
foundation
system of mathematics so it's kind of
more suitable to these
complicated up to homotopy structures
that uh
we're thinking about today well maybe
this is a good place to end up um
because in some sense like this all
it's kind of fun like i you and i are
both in the small group of people who
just think it's fun
thinking about this stuff right but um
it's also maybe a shift of
perspective on what math is right and in
changing what we mean by equality and
equivalence and
things like that and so can you imagine
that math is going to
look very different down the road when
when this really seeps in is it kind of
like a shift from
classical mechanics to quantum mechanics
in some sense yeah i think so
i think um you know we maybe see
glimpses of it today but i
you know i think you know every living
mathematician would be very surprised by
you know 22nd century mathematics and um
i hope to be around to see some of it
well i was very interested to read
uh there's a wonderful interview with
you in quantum magazine and one of the
interesting things you're doing is
writing books i mean maybe you count
them as textbooks but anyway technical
mathematical books where
correct me if i'm saying this wrong but
you were just as
interested in reproving known theorems
in
better ways as improving new theorems
which is supposed to be
the the typical thing mathematicians are
paid to do
right and you know there's this bill
thurston who is this uh wonderful
topologist geometer
um uh drew attention to
uh you know kind of the role that
mathematicians need to play in making
mathematics understandable to humans you
know so
you know because something has been
proven um that means it's true
which uh you know nice thing about
mathematics is the theorems that were
proven 2000 years ago are equally true
today
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's understandable by somebody who
wants to build on those ideas and use
them to do
something else so i think it is
worthwhile to do a bit of
you know kind of tidying up um
and repackaging streamlining um you know
a wonderful success in the history of
mathematics is
you know the these cutting-edge
discoveries that were you know kind of
very controversial or
inconceivable to somebody 100 years ago
are now stuff we teach undergraduates in
their first and second year
right i mean there was a lot of
controversy over calculus right that was
a that was considered hard yeah
right these pinnacles of human
achievement are now something that you
know
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
students are learning every single year
and i hope we continue to progress in
that way we should check back 30 years
from now we'll have you back on the
podcast and we'll check to see whether
or not category theory is taught to
uh at least undergraduates at least
first year students in the math classes
so
that's something to look forward to
emily real thanks very much for being on
the mindscape podcast
great thanks for having me
[Music]
you